Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have,
case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when his soul is taken away, Allah says
he's going to say what? Send me back to
do Hajj, umrah, salah, fasting. What? No
sodak. Brothers and sisters, is getting
thousands of shahadas monthly, yearly.
Hundreds of thousands of people are
coming to Islam. They are printing
Quran, distributing material, training
duat. Brothers and sisters, do you want
the part of that? That goes on forever.
This is how Islam has spread around the
world brother and sisters carry on this
legacy of the prophetam inshallah by
donating whatever amount inshallah and
support ayra right now inshallah enjoy
the video
to brothers and sisters and dear friends
and they are now turning against each
other. You're going to watch this video
guys with absolute peace and joy because
Allah says in the Quran which we're
going to read for oursel inshallah how
they look like they're united but they
are so disunited and it's so profound in
the verse in surah hasher verse 14 and
15 guess who it's talking about brothers
and sisters inshallah as you can see
we're going to watch this now let's
watch the video of these guys Jonathan
Conrias or whatever his name is the
coward absolute dirt bag let's see for
ourselves inshallah what he had to say
and how now he's turning against
Benjamin Netanyahu and his own
government. Listen to yourself.
>> And Jonathan, your response to start to
what we've just heard right now, this
recognition and what is likely to follow
next. Your thoughts.
>> I see clowns, losers, and terrorists.
And uh I am blunt, but yes, that this
recognition I think is clownish. It is
based on unound opinions. It is reckless
because it isn't based on any reality. I
think ambassador Alon said it very
succinctly. The Palestinian state meets
exactly none of the requirements of a
functioning state from all aspects and
therefore any forced recognition of such
a fictitious state is indeed clowning.
>> Fictitious state it's rich coming from
you. You know it reminds me of something
fictitious state. I wonder what's
fictitious state Palestine or Israel.
Like they say every accusation is a
confession. It brings me to the second
point and that is about the losers.
>> So you're you're the clown and now he
wants to talk about himself. So he spoke
about the clowns which is himself. Now
he's the loser. He's talking about
himself as well today. Gazans are
losers. Israelis today are losing. The
Israeli government lost and I think
missing.
>> Alhamdulillah. And may Allah make them
lose more inshallah.
>> From the prime minister statement in
Hebrew instead of only pointing fingers
outwards should be pointing backwards.
and at least in Hebrew acknowledging to
Israelis that yes, this is a colossal
diplomatic failure on his God. While he
is prime minister, we find ourselves
facing what is probably a lowest point
in the last 20, 30 or 40 years.
>> Wow. To his god. That's very bizarre.
This is a failure to his god. You see,
it's a for them it's a theological thing
them massacring because this is why it's
not political. It's not like um liberal.
It's it's it's the to them it's like a
theological thing that they're doing
that they're they're fighting. Okay? And
their war is men, women, and children
massacre them. That's why he said he's
failed against his god as you can see.
But let's carry on. He spoke about the
clowns which him himself and his
government. The losers is himself and
his government. And the terrorist is him
and himself and his government. And now
he's calling out Benjamin Netany. He's
saying look look you know you are to
blame. You are the to blame. is upset.
You know, you can see he's he's upset
>> and that's saying a lot.
>> So there you go, guys. Now, let's go to
the verse in the Quran cuz I found this
so profound, brothers and sisters.
Allahh says in surah hash, even united,
they would not dare fight against you
except from within fortified strongholds
of for behind walls. So this is talking
about um the treacherous Jews at the
time of the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him. Okay, we know they were not
all the same. There were those who uh if
I'm not mistake Abdam if I'm not
mistaken who accepted Islam genuine Jews
honest Jews who accepted Islam became
Muslims yes even though they were
ethnically Jew as well. So even united
they will not dare to fight you against
except from within fortified strongholds
or from behind walls. You can evidently
see what they're doing there. Their
malice for each other is intense. See we
look at them and think they're so
strong.
Their malice for each other is intense.
You think they are united yet their
hearts are divided. That is because they
are a people with no real understanding.
That's the reason why somebody said that
you know the reason why they are doing
what the crazy stuff is because they
want the whole world to hate them so
they can stand firm cuz their their
hatred is so intense to one another. The
only way they can come together is if
they're trying to get the whole world to
hate them so they can become you know
they can say look the only people that
we have around us is each other. That's
the only way they're trying to unite.
And even that's not working. And then
Allah says in uh the following verse in
verse 15 they are they are both just
like who's recently went down from them
they tasted the evil consequence of
their things and they will suffer
painful punishment and we know the
treachery that they done the treason
that they done that the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him bin if I'm not
mistaken um subhan Allah who gave and he
was one of them who gave the order that
600 of them be executed because of
treason because they did they
backstabbed and broke the treaty
alhamdulillah so you can clearly see
brothers and sisters Yeah. Uh like
people make it seem like dirtback Tommy
Robinson the shield. Yes. That's a good
good who makes it seem like yo they
killed uh innocent. No no no no. They
committed treason. Yes. They were not
innocent. They committed treason. So you
can see here brothers and sisters Allah
is telling us they look like their
hearts are united in rather it's not.
Their hatred for each other is intense.
And brothers and sisters you can see now
they are turning to each other against
each other. May Allah increase them in
that division. May Allah humiliate them.
And the entire world is seen it. And uh
Britain, Canada, and these other
countries who are trying to wash the
blood of their hands with the tap water,
the water from the tap that says free
Palestine is a state. Now we don't buy
it. We believe we're going to see that
when the future generation comes, you
played hand in hand a role in the
genocide that's taken today. Some is
estimating about 600,000 people have
been massacred. Brothers and sisters,
the whole world is seeing their evil.
Their reign is coming to an end. It's
the beginning of the end of Israel. They
are the ones who were behind Charlie
Kirk's assassination because he was
turning against them. Follow Candace
Owens. She's exposing them. Follow her
carefully because I'm listening to her
because very carefully if there's anyone
out there who is genuinely trying to
find out what happened, it's Candace
Owens inshallah. And God knows they're
going to come for her life. Bro,
sisters, I just wanted to leave it at
that. Inshallah, make dua that Allah
free the people of Palestine and they
are inshallah. And this is yet another
blow to Israel and the IDF soldiers who
have been liquidated left, right, center
by the resistance. Brothers and sisters,
till next time.